>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Welcome
to the National Book Festival.
I'm Barrie Hardymon.
I'm a books editor at NPR,
which is a media partner
of this fine festival.
I need to thank the co-chairman
of the festival, David Rubinstein,
and all the other sponsors who
have made this event possible
and continue to support
it year after year.
One more piece of business, cell
phones off or airplane mode.
I'm okay with airplane mode too.
Okay. Okay.
Down to business.
I'm so excited to talk
to Charlie Jane Anders.
She's the author of one of my
favorite books of the year.
It came out in January.
It is a one-sitting book, but
it is the kind, but you'll want
to stretch it out to five sittings.
It's called All the
Birds in the Sky.
Here, I happen to have
one right here.
She was a founding editor
of the website, IO9.
She's won a Hugo award
among other honors.
She's written all kinds of
other things that you can find
in collections and on the web.
I encourage you to Google here.
Hi.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Hi.
It's so good to be here.
>> Barrie Hardymon: So
can we start with the book
because I'm so, I loved it so much.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And I don't know
if our audience is familiar with it,
but just, let's give
them a little sense of it
because I have the feeling
when I was reading it
that the author's whole
self was in it.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh my gosh.
>> Barrie Hardymon: So I
think that will be a good way
to introduce them to you.
So let's sketch it
out for our audience.
The first act is like
a miso [phonetic],
called life for witches kind of
thing, like it's, it's too geeky,
junior high, outcast name,
Patricia and Lawrence, briefly,
they are a witch and
a mad scientist.
Can you just tell us a
little bit about them?
>> Yeah, I mean basically I wanted
to tell a coming of age story
which then includes what
happens after coming of age,
so the first like hundred pages of
the book is these characters as kids
in junior high school, and,
you know, everybody always says
that high school is
hell, but I really think
that junior high school is hell.
>> Barrie Hardymon: I agree.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Like I think
that when you have all these crazy
hormones and you're like dealing
with gleeks and bullies, and I think
it's just at its absolute worst
in like seventh and eighth grade.
That's when it's just
like the most horrific.
And so they're dealing with all this
stuff and they're also just trying
to figure out who they
are as like, you know,
someone who can do a little bit
of magic and occasionally talk
to animals and then someone else
who can build really weird gadgets
but doesn't have a lot of control
over, you know, his abilities
yet either, and so it's kind of like
trying to figure out who you are
and where you belong kind of stuff.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And I
love that their magic is
like sort of a bummer at first.
Like it's kind of like,
it's real junior high magic.
Like he makes a time machine that
like a two-second time machine.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Right.
Right, right.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And so there's
such a, it's such a cheeky sort
of look at how when you're in
junior high school everything feels
like a bummer, even your magical.
You don't know what your magic is.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Right, right.
>> Barrie Hardymon: You
know, because you have to get
out of junior high and high school
and sometimes the first year
of college [laughter] but--
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh my God.
>> Barrie Hardymon: So
then we jump ahead of it.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And because
they have to grow up to find
out that all the things that made
them different actually makes them
really awesome.
So they each go to school,
and when they reunite we are
in a precarious environment.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: So
what's the state of the world
when Patricia and Lawrence meet up?
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah,
I mean it's interesting.
Like the second like half or maybe
two-thirds of the book takes place
in the near future in San
Francisco, and it's, you know,
the world is kind of
falling apart a little bit.
It's not like, you know, some
kind of crazy doomsday scenario.
It's more just like a bunch of
things that are already going on,
have just gotten kind of worse,
like there's antibiotic-resistant
diseases and there's
like some problems with
drought and flooding
and just environmental
issues, and it's just--
things have gotten a little
bit harder in general.
And so I mean, you know, somebody,
earlier today I was being
interviewed for another thing,
and they used the D word.
Dystopia. And I was like, no,
no, no, don't use the D word.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Oh, I
was just about to use it.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh, no.
Sorry.
>> Barrie Hardymon:
No, I'm just kidding.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
And I was like, you know,
because everybody was like kind of
sick of dystopias right now thanks
to like, you know, the kind of
post-Hunger Games feeding frenzy.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Yeah,
the actual dystopia.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
Well there's also that.
But, you know, but it's also just,
I didn't think of it as a dystopia.
I thought of it as our world just a
little bit worse, and it gets worse
as the book goes on because of some
things that happen, but I wanted it
to be-- I didn't want it to be like
we're fighting the evil empire.
I wanted it to be like we're
just dealing with life,
and life can be really tough
sometimes, and I also thought
that that was a way to get at
some of these ideas of like,
you have a mad scientist and a
witch, so it's about like science
and nature, and thinking
about environmental problems
in particular is one of the ways
that we have to kind of think
about like nature and technology
and how they go together.
So that was kind of a thing that
I wanted to kind of slowly bring
to the present, bring to the
fore in the book without ever
like bludgeoning the
reader hopefully.
>> Barrie Hardymon: I love the--
one of the things that's so nice is
that that, that thing, the science
versus magic, which is at the heart
of this book, you know,
could have been a thing
where magic is the naturey,
you know, and the evil text,
but you're so, you clearly
love all of these things,
which, you know, we all should.
I want-- one particular item
that I really love in the future
and I'm really looking
forward to is the caddy.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Oh [laughter].
>> Barrie Hardymon: Which
is this iPod-like tablet.
I shouldn't say it, but it's a
tablet which makes your life better.
It will steer you toward
your people you'll like.
You can catch a bus more easily.
You'll avoid [inaudible].
It's like a serendipity machine.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Right.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And it kind
of may be what, like which is just
such a lovely way to look at a
technology, you know, the phone,
that is in my pocket right now.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Right.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And I still--
and like I touched it, and,
you know, we're all sort of,
you know, obsessed with it.
>> Right. Right.
>> It was such a-- you still have a
real fondness for technology as much
as magic, and I just-- like what's
your relationship to your phone
that you could create a
beautiful object like the caddy.
Like is this a hopeful vision of--
>> Charlie Jane Anders: I mean
I think it's a hopeful vision.
And like actually it was
funny because I was worried
that by the time the book
came out there was like a long
like two-year lead time from them
buying it to it getting published.
I was worried that the caddy
was already going to exist
by the time the book came out.
Like, I was like someone's going
to actually invent this thing,
and then it's going to be like,
oh, you know, but I don't know.
I mean I wanted to like, you know, I
didn't, like I think my early ideas
of the book were like all
the science was just going
to be way out, like ray guns
and space ships and, you know,
giant robots and stuff, and then
I was like I guess I got more
into thinking about like how
technology actually changing our
lives and how it actually
is kind of a real thing
and like how our gadgets have
kind of made everything different
and kind of just thinking about
like what if that was even better
or more, you know, more real.
>> Barrie Hardymon:
And more empathetic.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: You know,
in general, I wanted to avoid,
like you mentioned about the sort
of witch, the naturey kind of,
you know, earth mother
kind of thing, I wanted to,
I mean that's in there a little bit,
but I wanted to avoid
playing to the stereotypes
>> Barrie Hardymon: You avoid it.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: And
I wanted to be like okay,
one of the first things we find
out about when we meet some
of the other witches is that one
of them loves microwave ovens,
just like loves microwave ovens,
and like he just will go on about
like my life has been
changed by the microwave,
like I can't believe I can just
put things in it and then it's hot
and it's awesome, and like, you
know, and like, I don't know,
I lived in a Buddhist
nunnery when I was a teenager,
and all the nuns had cell phones
and like they were all like riding
around on little motorcycle
scooters, and like they were not
like avoiding technology at all.
It's lovely that you've made this,
I'm not going to say dystopia,
but you've made this near future
that has turned, you know, 11.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Right.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: You've
made it really relatable
and very, very, it's very funny.
I think there's something, I just
wonder, what's so funny about the,
there's something about, well how do
you find that humor as the world is
in really dire straits in
all of these ways that,
you know, I could see happening.
I mean there is a path to
this world that you lay out.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah,
I mean it's interesting.
The thing about the humor,
like you mentioned humor
and also relatability, that
like, you know, you can relate
to the characters and it feels real.
That was actually something
that I struggled with a lot
in writing this book, and there
was a draft it like, you know,
fairly late in the process that
was a lot funnier and more kind
of like satirical and, you
know, more slap sticky.
There was more just kind of like
zany mishaps, and what I found was
like the humor in this
particular book only seemed to work
if it was very close to the
characters and if it was
like the characters actually kind
of laughing at their situation
or if it was something that was
sympathetic to the characters even
when we're kind of making
fun of them a little bit.
And I found that like, you
know, humor can kind of,
like I love absurdism, and I
love that there's kind of an,
there's some absurd elements
to this kind of weird future,
but at the same time I just wanted
to, you know, it's very easy
to get sidetracked
to laughing at it,
and I wanted to keep it very
close to the emotion and the core
of what they're, what they're
feeling, and how they're,
and the relationship between
the two main characters.
And so I actually kept dialing
back the humor in the book and kind
of making it, consciously making it
a little bit less funny and going
for kind of whimsical rather
than just kind of like up like,
you know, actual comedy I guess.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Yeah, and
it is, I mean it does have that,
I mean it is at its heart,
it's a love story, as you say.
It's really the story
of Patricia and Lawrence
and I think how they are
discovering how they affect others,
and they have these other powers
that are, you know, beyond us.
I wonder, when you think about, the
way that these two characters act
in a story is very much the way any
two characters acting would fall
in love.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: In any world.
So I guess I wanted to ask you,
because this is one of these books.
When I recommend it to
people I can pick any genre
and say it's this,
it's this, it's this.
There's so much in it.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Awesome, hey, that's awesome.
>> Barrie Hardymon: But what does
genre mean for you when you're,
when you're making these characters
and placing them in a world,
as a writer, like what
is making that world?
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
I mean, you know, it's--
I feel like writing this book
in particular really changed
how I think about genre.
Like I thought of it originally
as like the meeting of two genres
and like you have fantasy
and you have science fiction,
and they have different expectations
of what's going to happen
in the story and different
ideas about how the world works,
and I found that meeting really
interesting and like, you know,
it was originally going
to be just kind
of almost spoofing the
two genres in the process
of bumping them against each other.
But over the course of writing
it, you know, it became more
of a relationship story, and the
approach to genre became much more
like these are two different world
views that these characters have,
and in particular like, you know,
one of the things that I did
when I was revising the book
endlessly was like I just would,
you know, kind of peep myself
up and ask like what is this,
what am I actually, what's really
going on here, what's really going
on with these characters?
Why are they acting like this?
What am I trying to explore here?
What am I thinking?
Why am I doing this in this book?
And I kind of felt like genre became
a way of kind of focusing intent
and having more intentionality.
I kind of feel like the unexamined
story is not worth writing in a way.
And like I'm a big believer in kind
of just continuing to pull it apart
over and over again, and so for me
in the end genre became, you know,
the failure mode of genre is
that it dictates what's going
to happen in this story.
Like it's a thriller, so there's got
to be a ticking time
bomb on page 300.
There's got to be a building,
or a hundred buildings
blowing up on page 400.
There's got to be a car chase,
or whatever, and that's sort
of a failure mode, but I think
that what genre can do wonderfully
is kind of just focus you
on a particular set of ideas
or a particular set of meanings
or world views and let you kind
of delve into that and think
about like what is this
actually, why is this so powerful,
why is this speaking to
me and how can I help it
to speak to other people kind of.
>> Barrie Hardymon: It's really a,
because there are so many elements
in it, and there are a lot
of what's really pleasurable
for whether you know the
reference or not or that it is sort
of crammed full of a lot of, you
know, like Rendorf [phonetic]
and Dr. Who, and there are all
these Easter eggs for, you know,
but I can still give this book to my
mother, and she would still love it
on the merits of not
knowing Dr. Who.
But that's so, but I
guess what I wonder,
as you were building this world,
which has a lot of, as you say,
different world moods, is there a
fear, was there an editing process
where you worried about diluting by,
do you know what I mean,
like so many genres?
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Yeah, I mean,
I wasn't worried about diluting.
I mean in general, like even from
early on with this book I felt like,
you know, I had like, you kind
of make a bargain with the reader
in a way in terms of like how
much stuff you can get away
with putting into a book.
Like how many different weird
elements you could put into a book
and like, you know, okay, so if
I've got like this super computer,
and I've got this like,
you know, magical tree,
and I've got this other stuff, you
know, are people going to be like,
okay, that's it, that's all we're
going to let you have, you know,
you kind of have, like, no more.
We've accepted those things, we're
not going to accept anything else.
And like the bargain I kept making
in my head with the reader was okay,
you know, you go with me for like
the talking birds on page three
or whatever, you go with
me for this other stuff.
I'm going to, the promise
that I make to you in return
for accepting all this outlandish
stuff that kind of doesn't seem
like it ought to fit together
in one book is that I'm going
to stay super narrowly focused on
these two characters, and it's going
to be very emotionally grounded,
and I'm never going to let all
of the shiny objects
kind of distract me
from the story of these two people.
And I feel like as long
as I kept playing off
that promise I could get away with
kind of working in more stuff.
And there was also stuff that was
just at margins so that like some
of the geekiest stuff in the book,
you know, wasn't like, you know,
you have to understand this to
get what's going on kind of.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Yeah,
they're just little Easter
eggs that are there for you.
What's so satisfying about, because
it is, about having two people
from different worlds-- I guess
I'm about to ask you what's
so satisfying about
world's colliding, I guess,
what about people's
worlds' colliding.
I just, it's such a, especially
when it comes to this kind
of people that wouldn't normally.
Like I can't think of
another book in which a witch
and a scientist have
this relationship.
You know. And there's something
so satisfying about it,
and with these two characters, I
just am, what was so satisfying
about writing this match.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
I mean I think it was,
again it was the world views, like
you mentioned, and it was this idea
of like, you know, getting to
kind of explore magic in science
but also this think of like figuring
out who you are and like, you know,
what I found really interesting,
like I wanted to have that thing
where there are kids and then there
are adults, partly, like I said,
to do the thing of like what
happens after you come of age,
but also I found it
really interesting
to see how their relationship
changes when they're adults
versus when they're kids.
Like they're such different
people as adults,
but all that history is still
there, and so I got really excited
to see how their relationship
kind of evolved in adulthood, and,
you know, I think in
general I've always really,
I think that the romance
in particular is a genre
that lends itself super well to like
very different world views and like,
you know, I actually
kind of hate that movie,
but You've Got Mail, or whatever--
>> Barrie Hardymon: Oh yeah, yeah.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Where he's like the big,
the Borders bookstore guy and
she's the like small bookstore--
>> Barrie Hardymon: The
shop around the corner.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Like
he drives her out of business
or whatever, and like it's
a weird, weird, weird movie,
but that's the kind of
quintessential thing
of like they have radically
different viewpoints
and opposing ideas and like how
can they make it work or whatever,
and the reason I hate
that movie is not so much
because of the bookstore stuff,
which is a little bit, gets kind of,
it's weird how it touches on that,
but also just the fact that he knows
from early on the movie who she is,
and she doesn't find out who he is
until the end and there's
this weird power differential
that movie totally loves, but
anyway, that's a [inaudible].
>> Barrie Hardymon: I am
totally with you on that.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: You know, I
was just, I hadn't thought for years
about how much I hate that movie,
but that movie, I hated it.
Anyways, so--
>> Barrie Hardymon:
It's a great love letter
to the upper west side,
but that's about it.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh my God.
Yeah, anyways, sorry,
that was a total sidebar.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Sorry.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: But
that thing, and like, you know,
part of what happened with this
book is I had written the story,
Six Months, Three Days, that was
another kind of love story which we,
two clairvoyants, and you know,
she sees many different
possible futures,
and he sees one fixed future, so
it was like almost the purest form
of like we have incompatible
views of the world,
and how do you make that work.
And so I kind of loved
doing that, and I, you know,
I feel like after this I don't
want to do it again for a while,
but I really enjoyed doing it.
>> Barrie Hardymon: So no sequel?
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh
there's, no, there's no sequel.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Really?
I read, [inaudible]
I thought maybe, no?
>> Charlie Jane Anders: No.
I mean I don't know how
you follow up that ending,
but also I do have
a short story coming
out at some point about
Patricia's cat.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Oh.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Because
I've had people come up to me
and be like, you know,
what happened to the cat.
>> Barrie Hardymon:
That's a good question.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: And like
I've had people be like, you know,
I would have liked this book except
that there's the cat loose end like,
and I can't like a book where the
cat is not dealt with or whatever.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Right.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Dealt
with is a sense of like, you know,
but where the cat's going to walk.
>> Barrie Hardymon: I think
that's a great episode title,
dealing with the cat.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
So there's the story about the cat,
but other than that, no, no sequel.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Okay.
All right.
I'll get over it.
But so I do want to ask you,
because I know we're not going
to use the D word, but there's
definitely some depression
happening, some sadness
happening in the world.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Right.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And if humanity
is on the verge of, in the book,
humanity is clearly on the
verge of destroying itself,
and everybody has different ideas
about what drastic
measures need to be taken.
I guess, what is your
thought, is this something on,
I always want to ask people
who write about this, you know,
the future that looks scary
about what, is this something
that keeps you up at night or
does it, is it a soothing balm
to the, a flood that you see.
Do you know what I mean?
Does it, is it cathartic,
or is it something
that you think about in another way.
Are you working it out on the page?
What are you working
out on the page?
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
I mean first of all I want
to point out that actually
in the book I'm very
careful to make it clear
that people have the opinion
that humanity is on the verge
of destroying itself, and actually
I have one character at one point
who says, oh, people are
just being drama queens
and this is just an adjustment
in our standard of living,
and we'll be fine, and I wanted
to include that in there partly
because I feel like you would
never really know for sure,
like it's not like there would
be like a giant billboard,
and like one of the things that,
getting back to the ticking
time bomb that you have
in like a thriller sometimes, I
wanted it to be very much like,
well, there may be a catastrophe
that ends the human race due to some
of the things that have happened,
and it, we think it's likely,
we think it might be in the next
anywhere from six months to 20
or 30 years, and like I feel like--
>> Barrie Hardymon:
That's not helpful.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: I
feel like that kind of in,
that kind of indistinct
timeline or whatever,
that kind of confusing timeline,
makes it feel more real to me,
that like, you know, versus
like where there's like a clock
or something, but, yeah,
I mean I feel like,
I mean Kim Stanley Robinson
has talked about this a lot,
and if you ever get a chance to
hear him speak, he's incredible.
He talks about a lot in his books
he deals a lot with the idea that,
you know, environmental crisis
or environmental problems are
in our future, and you can't
really write about the future
without at least dealing with that
idea that there's going to be,
that the icecaps are going to
melt, there's going to be flooding,
we're going to have some problems.
There's going to be food shortages.
And I do worry about that a lot, and
I do feel kind of a responsibility
to kind of, to at least touch on
that in the book, and it did kind
of play into the whole science
and nature thing, and I, again,
not wanting to like bludgeon
or lecture the reader,
I wanted to at least include,
I mean I think it's something
that everybody worries about to some
extent if you are paying attention
to what's happening in the news
and to what science is telling us
about our, you know, perhaps
not terribly distant future,
it's something that's a huge source
of anxiety for a lot of people.
I think that there's,
I mean, you know,
obviously post-apocalyptic stories
have an element of wish fulfillment
if you get to be one of the
lucky, people who survive the end
of the world, and if you
neighbors become zombies you get
to shoot your neighbors in the
head, and that's kind of awesome.
But, you know, they'll
never complain
about my noise again [gun
cocking noise], you know.
>> Barrie Hardymon: I'm going to
have the biggest party [laughter].
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Yeah, anyway.
You know, and you get to like just,
you never have to go to work again.
You never have to get
another oil change ever again
for as long as you live.
You don't have to worry about
your mortgage ever again.
But, you know, I think
that it's something
that we're all a little
bit, you know, terrified of,
and I think that, you know, I've
always thought science fiction
and fantasy has like a unique
ability and maybe even a duty
to deal with the big questions
about what's going to happen to us,
and I feel like, in a very
small way I try to kind
of grapple with that in this book.
>> Barrie Hardymon:
I like to, there's a,
like I said it's very relatable,
and there is this feeling that,
you know, as, as maybe
the apocalypse approaches
like people are still going to maybe
be on social media and they're going
to be complaining about hipsters.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And
they're going to, you know,
have this real emotional
life, and it's funny,
but it's also really this
kindness, this kind of domesticness
to the way that, you know, because
it always bothers me in those movies
where you would think that
somebody would be like,
do you think this is it.
But your characters do have,
like there is this kind of,
there's a real talk about,
you know, where humanity it.
And I guess that kind of really
brings me to the, like you said,
there's the part of the like
moving toward the long slide,
and then there's a post.
Does the post, does that
world interest you at all,
or are you really just into
the slide, or is the journey--
>> Charlie Jane Anders: I feel like
at this point I've read and seen
so many post-apocalyptic stories
that it would be really hard for me
to come up with one that
excited me to write.
I mean I've written a
couple of short stories
that are post-apocalyptic, that
have like a different twist on it,
but I feel like that's, you
know, one of the most kind
of commonly used story
settings or ideas right now.
It's the kind of after the
apocalypse, And I don't know,
it's hard for me to even imagine
writing that at this point.
I mean my next novel I'm working
on right now is actually set
on another planet and like maybe
a thousand years in the future
with humans colonizing
another planet,
and I feel like in a way people
having to live on another planet
with just whatever we brought from
earth and whatever we can scrounge
on the planet's surface is kind of
like a post-apocalyptic scenario
in a way because, you know,
you arrive with a certain
amount of civilization.
>> Barrie Hardymon:
Limited [inaudible].
Yeah.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
You have your awesome computers
and your shiny machines,
and then maybe a few
hundred years go by.
A lot of those things break down.
You can't necessarily
get the silicone
or whatever else you
need to fix them.
Maybe it's not as easy
to get back up into orbit
as you thought it was
going to be, and you know,
things just get tougher,
and so that's kind of like,
I've thought about how
that's kind of my answer
to doing a post-apocalyptic story
is just do a story on another planet
where it's just, things are really
different, and trying to hold
onto civilization is kind of hard.
>> Barrie Hardymon: I think you
just answered another question
that I had, but I--
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Sorry.
>> Barrie Hardymon: No, that's good.
I can, I'm following up, which
is when you thought about this,
it seems like Patricia
and Lawrence came first.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: But here you're
talking about setting coming first.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh, yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: But how
do you, how do you grapple
with like the world or the people
you're going to put in the world
as you create your story, as
you do your story telling.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah,
I mean it's really tough.
Every story, every novel is
different, and like All the Birds
in the Sky definitely started
with these two characters
and nothing else, and it
was just like what kind
of world does it make sense for
them to be in, and you know,
especially with Patricia, I had to
come up with a whole world of magic
that she could belong to
that was not just, you know,
a painted backdrop or like she'll
go to a school called Hogfarts
or whatever, you know,
[laughter] I don't know.
I had to come up with something
that was different and, you know,
hopefully unique and interesting in
its own way, and with Lawrence I had
to come up with a world of like
[inaudible] that felt like our world
but different in an interesting way.
And so, you know, sometimes you
start with characters and you kind
of work your way up to setting,
and then with this next book,
I started with setting, and I
had some ideas about characters,
but that's been a real struggle.
It's been a very different approach
to writing, and it's been kind of,
you know, the last couple years
have been really interesting.
I've been kind of banging my
head up against the wall trying
to like create characters
who feel real
in this very different setting that,
you know, I can get excited about.
>> Barrie Hardymon:
That's interesting.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: And it's
only been in the last few months
that I've really felt
like I've gotten there.
So it's been really tough.
>> Barrie Hardymon: I read that your
first novel was a literary novel
of just a like, not
magic, not sci-fi.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: It started
in this other, this other world,
and I wonder how did you then make
the trip to the other, to genre.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Yeah, I mean it's,
I had an interesting relationship
with genre over the years.
Like I started out my first like few
years writing fiction I was writing
nothing but science fiction and
got almost none of it published,
or it was published in
very small magazines.
And then I decided to
try writing other genres,
and I wrote a few things,
but I wrote,
I wrote a lot of literary fiction,
and I actually got published
in some pretty decent
literary magazines.
And like I had a thing
in McSweeney's and stuff.
And what I found interesting about
the literary fiction was, you know,
it forced me to stop thinking in
terms of like a plot device or like,
okay, what if there's like a space
ship that can go faster than light
but only if everybody on board
is feeling guilty or something,
which was one of my really
dumb stories that I wrote.
Don't even ask.
It was a terrible story.
>> Barrie Hardymon: That's like
my mother' car, I like that.
[laughter] Just kidding.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
But you know, so I had,
I was coming up with lots
of like zany plot devices
and zany plot ideas, and so
writing literary fiction was one way
to force myself to kind of think
just in terms of character.
And that novel actually was one
where like I wrote a bunch of stuff,
and like there was one character
who was a really minor character,
who just I got interested in,
and I just started writing
about that character,
Barry, almost exclusively,
and that became the story of this
one character, that just came
out of all these other characters
who failed to be main characters.
And so that was a really fun
process, but I wrote a lot of,
I still write, quote,
unquote, literary fiction,
occasionally without genre
elements, and it's fun.
It's fun to just sort
of have like characters
in a situation that's quote,
unquote, realistic, and there's no
like what if element, and I
felt like when I went back
to writing science fiction and
fantasy, I kind of brought more
of that back with me a little
bit, and I was able to just think
about character a little bit
earlier in the process maybe
than I had been doing before.
>> Barrie Hardymon:
That's interesting.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: And so
it was a good side trip actually,
it was a good--
>> Barrie Hardymon: But you
started with science fiction.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And then
went-- oh that's interesting.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: And my
early science fiction was terrible.
I mean my early literary, my
early everything was terrible,
and maybe in a few years
from now I'll look back
at what I'm writing now and be
like, oh that was terrible, but,
you know, I don't think, anyway.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Did you always
know you'd make the trip back
to science fiction and fantasy?
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Probably
because that's like my first love,
and that's what I've always
been most passionate about.
I mean I've read, like I love
reading literary fiction.
I've read like just tons
and tons of it, but I just,
science fiction has a special
place in my heart, so--
>> Barrie Hardymon: What
did you read as a kid?
>> Charlie Jane Anders: As a kid,
I mean, I read a lot of like,
you know, I was in England
for a while, so I read a lot
of like Paddington
Bear book and like,
I loved Lloyd Alexander's
Chronicles of Prydain.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Yeah.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Those are so great.
Madeleine L'Engle.
Madeleine L'Engle was huge
for me when I was a kid.
Judy Blume.
Just all that stuff, I don't know.
>> Barrie Hardymon: So when you dove
into sci-fi, what was your gateway?
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Probably Douglas Adams.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Oh yeah.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: I
think Douglas Adams was like.
That was, I mean there were other
authors I read before Douglas Adams,
but he was one that was just like,
you know, wacked over the head
with like a two by four, and he's
always going to be like the kind
of platonic ideal of what
great writing is to me kind of.
He's so, like he just sets up
all these interesting situations,
and he's so funny, and, you know,
he just has this ability to kind
of just get to the heart
of like what makes something
ridiculous in like a few sentence.
>> Barrie Hardymon: That
is a thing about sci-fi,
is that there is a sense of
like you can be ridiculous.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: In a way
that you almost can't
as much with fantasy.
Fantasy seems to have
it, to have more pride.
It's not the right word, but
the thing I like about sci-fi,
I mean I like them both
obviously, is that you have a,
sci-fi allows you to do the crazy,
the compute is talking to you,
and then it explodes in a
spaceship of guilt, you know.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>> Barrie Hardymon: But
what's freeing about fantasy?
What's the freedom
in fantasy to you.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: I mean,
I'm going to disagree slightly
because I think Terry Pratchett is
like one of the funniest writers.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Oh yeah.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
And I feel like--
>> Barrie Hardymon: That's true.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
You know, he's,
I mean it's almost gotten harder to
be funny in science fiction the last
like 20 or 30 years because it's
gone through more of a phase
of taking itself seriously
again, I don't know.
I think these things go
in phases or in waves.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Yeah.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: I think
that the thing about fantasy is
that people get very
obsessed with the idea
that magic should have
rules, which is, you know,
there's a debate actually.
N.K. Jemisin wrote a really amazing
essay a few years ago saying no
magic doesn't have to have rules,
it just has to make sense,
which is the same thing.
Makes sense is like also like kind
of for some values it
makes sense kind of.
It has to just not feel like oh
anything can happen, it's magic,
like, you know, whoo, nothing
matters, I can just, you know,
any obstacle I can just walk
through because it's magic.
You know, that kind of thing.
But I think people get
very obsessed with the idea
that magic should have
rules, and especially
since George R. Martin came
along, there's this idea
that magic should be
something that's not
like overpowering in the world.
Like Game of Thrones was like
a huge breath of fresh air
because it's a world
that feels like just a,
kind of a naturalistic medieval
world, and there's just a little bit
of magic in the first book, and
then it slowly kind of ratchets up.
And I think people have
really embraced that.
So I think if you try to just
go broadly comic with magic now,
people might feel like okay you're
not taking it seriously enough,
magic has to be respected.
And I understand where that's
coming from because it's, you know,
it's easy to just go, like I said,
go crazy with like
anything can happen, whoo,
and like that just gets annoying.
So I think you have to respect,
you have to treat it right.
>> Barrie Hardymon: And in
this book you really do.
I note that you have healer
magic and trickster magic, right.
You should explain that particular
role, because it's really,
it's a lovely, it's a lovely idea.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah, I
mean I was thinking, like I said,
I was thinking about
like a world of magicians
and how I could make it different
from all these other fantasy
books I'd been reading,
and somehow I stumbled on,
after like hours of just
like banging my head against the
wall, I stumbled on this idea
that like there were these
two schools of magic,
and it felt like a way to kind of
honor the fact that there was a lot
of different kinds of ways of
practicing magic in the real world.
There were these two
schools of magic.
Healer magic, which was just
sort of what it sounds like,
you could use it to heal people.
You have to build a certain kind of
bond or connection with them usually
to use it, and then trickster magic,
where you can do almost anything
if you can trick someone, if
you can like convince someone
to like make a bargain with you
or if you can hoodwink someone
in some way, you can get them
to give you all sorts of power.
And these two schools had actually
been at odds for a long time
and had almost gone to war,
and now they've been merged,
and actually there was a sub-plot
that I had to cut out of the book
where towards the end of the
book you find out that the truce
between trickster magic and
healer magic isn't as complete
as you thought and there's a
whole extra layer that I just was
like this is too complicated,
it's got to go.
But I can tell you about it after.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Okay, good.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: But
anyway, and I just liked the idea
that there was a history, and I came
up with a very complicated history,
most of which is not in the
book, about how this came to pass
and about how the war was averted.
There was this woman who was an
escaped slave from Barbados who went
and became the greatest trickster
magician the world had ever known,
and she was the one who
convinced them that tricksters
and healers work better
together and that, you know,
each can do the other kind of magic.
So that was something that
I really, I loved that idea
that there had been like
this complicated history,
that we only just touch on.
>> Barrie Hardymon: I feel like
I should open this operation
to other people who may want to ask.
Anybody want to come up to the mic?
>> I was wondering, one of
the things you said struck me,
and that was with your work on
IO9, you were exposed to so much
of everything that's going on
with science fiction and fantasy,
do you think that ultimately
that gives you inspiration
because you get so many different
ideas or is it intimidating
because any idea you can come
up with you can think somebody
else has already done it.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: You
know, it's a little of both.
I really, when I was doing
IO9, I worried a lot at first
that I was going to either
just get so like overwhelmed
with like all the great and in some
cases not great science fiction
and fantasy that I was reading and
watching and everything and also
that my kind of critic voice would
get so loud that I wasn't going
to be able to write, like I'd
just be constantly in critic mode
or just constantly in snark mode or
whatever, and I found that actually
for the most part, like it was
intimidating at times, like,
you know, it's still intimidating
when I go to conventions
and see all these writers whose
work I'm just like, you know,
I've been in awe for
example, but at the same time,
I just found it really like
getting, I talk about it
as like getting paid
to go to grad school.
Like I just got paid to read
so many great books and geek
out about stories and have all
these conversations with the readers
of IO9 who were, you know, this
incredibly smart group of people
who had like, I would come
out with a half, whatever,
half-baked opinion, and they
would kind of come in with
like all these interesting
ideas about it.
And like it was just really fun.
It was getting to like have
seminars every day, and like I just,
I found that like my ideas
about like what works
and what doesn't work in stories
got a lot sharper after a few years
of doing that because I would
have to think about like, okay,
where did, you know, where did this
thing go wrong, or what's like,
you know, the one thing
I keep coming back
to for some reason today is
Looper, the Rian Johnson movie,
how is that movie so great in
terms of how it uses time travel
to tell this story,
how can I study that.
And just like, yeah, it was actually
in the end I felt like, you know,
I mean if I start to think of
myself as trying to be as good
as those creators then I get a
complex, but getting paid to think
about these things and how they work
and what makes them work
was actually super awesome.
>> Thank you.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Thank you.
Hi.
>> Hi. My question is also
tangentially IO9 related.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Okay.
>> Just as, speaking as
someone who really hopes
to make this lead myself
at some point, what is the,
just the thought process like when
you finally decide, all right,
I'm just gritting my teeth and
making fiction writing my day job.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh man.
Yeah it's, I'm still, I'm still
second guessing that decision.
I don't know, it's really tough.
You know, basically what it was
is I needed a break from blogging.
I had been doing it for eight and
a half years, and I just wanted
to kind of take a step back
and not do that for a while.
And All the Birds in the Sky
seemed to be getting, you know,
people seemed to like it, and I
was like also having that problem
that I mentioned earlier where I'd
been working on this other book
for like two plus years,
and I still didn't feel
like I had a handle on it.
I had this setting that I had
spent so much time developing
that I still think is
an amazing setting,
and the characters were not
working at all, and I was just
like this needs my
undivided attention.
But what I was, what I said was like
okay, I'll leave my job at the end
of April and I'll give myself three
months to just work on fiction.
At the end of that time, I'll
reassess, so like August.
And I guess I'm still,
it's September now,
and I still haven't gotten another
job yet, so I guess it's going okay.
It's like, you know, I'm
taking it month by month.
It's not like it's permanent.
I'll see what my bank account
looks like in another few months
and also like, you know,
I'm just like eating a lot
of ramen noodles, I don't know.
But, you know, also just how
productive I can be every day.
I feel like being your own boss,
like I'm the worst
boss I've ever had.
I'm really hard on myself if I'm
not like constantly just producing
like tons and tons of stuff.
I'm really mean to myself about
that, and like so I'm still figuring
out like, someone who
had made the leap
to full-time fiction writer told me,
give yourself six months to figure
out the routine and how
you're actually doing it,
because it might take that long
before you actually know what your
day looks like, just
writing fiction every day.
Like that's the big thing,
is just can I produce enough.
So far, most of the time, yes.
Like, you know, things happen.
There's like a health emergency
in the family, and I have to,
but that would happen anyway.
So, so far it's, you
know, it's going okay,
but it's definitely a thing where
I'm kind of dipping a toe in.
I don't know.
>> Thank you.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: All right.
>> Barrie Hardymon: Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry, I didn't
know there was another.
>> That's okay.
My question is, well I
read Six Months Three Days.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh yeah?
>> And I really loved it.
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
Oh, thank you, yes.
Oh, sorry.
>> When I finished it I was
kind of mad that it wasn't much,
much longer, like a whole novel
or something, but there was also,
after I reflected on it, this like,
it felt like very purely distilled
down to the entire story, like the
fewest details kind of, to tell it,
and decided I liked that.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Oh good.
>> But then reading All the Birds
in the Sky, I just wonder for you,
what's the decision about whether
something is longer or shorter
or is it just that you write it and
then that's the length that it is.
Did you set out to
write this as a novel
or was it originally a short story
and it was just too big,
or how does that work.
>> Charlie Jane Anders: Yeah, I
mean that's always a tough decision
like whether something should
be a short story or a novel.
You know, there was like a period
for a while, like a few years ago
when I wrote a bunch of things
that I was like oh this is going
to be a novel, and then
it became a short storey.
That happened like over
and over again for a while,
and I don't know why
that was happening,
but I got some good
short stories out of it.
I think Six Months, Three Days I
always thought was a short story,
like maybe there was a minute
when I was like oh can I make this
that much longer, and I was like no,
because you have to pay off that,
like, it's got to have like,
you got to pay off that thing
in a reasonable amount of time, you
can't keep peddling or whatever.
And like, yeah, so it was
just like that clearly had
to be a short story, and with
All the Birds in the Sky,
I always thought of it as the novel,
I think just because the whole idea
of the witch and the mad scientist
felt like something that had
so much potential and so
many ways that it could go,
and like then when I had this
idea of like oh, then were kids,
and then there were adults,
that just felt like something
that I was pretty sure I
could make into a novel.
And like I know there are authors
who like get 100 pages into a novel
and then just, they can't go any
further and they throw it away
and they start over again, or
whatever, and that's never happened
to me, but I have written a bunch
novels that never got published.
But, yeah, I feel like, I don't know
if I've gotten a better instinct.
I feel like the thing, I wrote a
thing on IO9 about how can you tell
if your novel is just an
overgrown short story,
which is on there somewhere.
I feel like the metric or the
decision tree is mostly just,
you know, are there a lot of
kind of ramifications that I want
to play out, are there a lot of
like extra kind of nooks and alleys
that I want to look down that
are going to make this rewarding
at that length, or
can I distill it down.
I feel like if you can distill it
down you always kind of should.
Like I feel like shorter is
always better, like, you know,
never waste the reader's
time if you can avoid it,
I guess, is always a good rule.
>> Barrie Hardymon:
I'm sorry to tell you
that we have to wrap this up.
The book is All the
Birds in the Sky.
This is Charlie Janes Anders.
[ Applause ]
>> Charlie Jane Anders:
That went really fast.
>> Barrie Hardymon: I know, right.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.